so let's look at another feature that is
needed to build scalable applications
task queues so why do we need task
queues well at this time this picture
should be no surprise to you our dear
users accessing our App Engine
application from various devices and our
application returning the response
technically this response must be
returned within 60 seconds from their
request but that's a long time we've
talked about the importance about
returning a response as quickly as
possible to our dear users and we don't
want them to wait even for seconds right
and certainly not 60 seconds you want to
deliver that response as quickly as
possible but let's say that the user
activity triggers something big to
happen for example the user adds a new
conference and as a consequence of that
10,000 emails should be sent out to
notify other users about this conference
first of all that's not possible within
60 seconds and secondly you certainly
don't want the poor user that just
registered the conference to wait for
this to happen
remember the screen update depends on
your response
so even seconds are crucial to keep your
application responsive come to the
rescue
or toss queues this is exactly the
problem tasks you solve and it may not
be emails triggering the need for this
it could be something else
for example an image needs to be
analyzed or a video needs to be
reincarnated to complete the request for
the user could use task queues